quelle est votre vision justement vous
si vous devenez maire de lons le saunier
des rapports entre la mairie et
l'agglomération
déjà si je deviens maire je serai un
maire à 100% et je ne serai pas comme
monsieur le bois qui veut cumuler la
mairie la présidence de l'agglo le
conseiller départemental
j'ai encore pas très bien compris si
vous vouliez continuer votre métier ou
pas parce que une fois vous aviez dit
rouler vont être habitants d'autres fois
vous avez dit vous voulez continuer donc
monsieur le bois dites moi quelle est
votre position par rapport à ce cumul de
travail et demandent à est dit
clairement aux électrices et aux
électeurs
est ce que vous voulez cumuler toutes
les indemnités monsieur ravier vous nous
fait un procès d'intention et à travers
votre dernière phrase celle là même que
vous aviez dans le journal ce matin est
ce que vous avez dit dans votre facebook
live ou là par rapport à votre problème
c'est la notion de cumul d'indemnités
moi je suis sur le cumul d'efficacité
alors si on prend les villes préfecture
de belfort de besançon et de vesoul
les maires de chacune de ces villes son
président l'accord d'hier c'est une
bonne chose
adam hall c'est pas la même chose ce sa
famille vit très bien sûr ce ne sont pas
des villes préfectures sur sur sur un
autre point
j'ai été assez claire quand on est
candidat pour être président d'une
agglomération bien comprendre si vous
devenez mer dimanche vous serez candidat
à la tête de l'agglo marge de serait
candidat les maires des communes
environnantes ne veulent pas de vous
monsieur bois et non pas qu ils n'ont
pas confiance en vous ils sont ils sont
sur un seul plateau on peut pas leur
demander leur avis je veux garder leur
état d'attenté mais s'il sait des
partages de crise aux indemnités vous
voulez cumuler toutes les indemnités
mais vous pouvez faire plusieurs métiers
aura mais attendez je l'attendais soit
indemnité qu'on soit clair moi je je ne
me bats pas un jour contre l'évolution
d'indemnités du maire de lons pour dire
après jeunes à descendrait pas et moi
j'ai des cendres et les indemnités si je
suis élu parce que je suis ce sursis
vous en cumulé plusieurs voitures mais
pas aussi
oh c'est réaliste de toute façon limité
par la loi exactement voilà merci
monsieur est sûre le conseil
départemental lancer une discussion que
j'ai justement avec clément pernot et
daniel diebold bois quelle est la
meilleure efficacité du maire de lons
pour faire défend et pour défendre ses
dossiers
je n'ai pas encore la réponse on verra
déjà si les grands électeurs d'éclat
dont confiance vous voulez être candidat
au conseil départemental les prochaines
vous dit pas non donc vous voulez parce
que je ne sais pas si je serai maison de
l'agglomération
je ne serai pas un cumul il laisse la
porte ouverte
un moment